we're gonna start with a little clown my
hound up first this is Dawson from Las
Vegas and his dog will oh god damn bro
that's a horse it's a clown my how not
clown my [ __ ] Clydesdale thing is
jacked Wow is that Luke Rockhold bro
that is a he oh wow look at the puppy is
that Dwayne the rock Johnson splice it
looked like definitely there's been some
crossbreeding going on dude he's so big
I love Great Danes too man
but how much can you love him because I
mean look at the thighs on that thing
huh so do you want a thug can you zoom
in on those [ __ ] thought yachties
right there
we're being a village you kill that
thing bro oh yeah can't what do you
think about this kind of pup have you
seen these in your area growing they're
not walking around Koreatown nope I have
never seen a dog that big before it's
bigger than me yeah oh yeah you could
ride it cat you could ride that thing oh
my god that'd be beautiful wouldn't that
be fun to watch have you very played
genuine rabbit my saddle compound it
remember that you ready dude I remember
imagine cat slow-motion oh yeah what
happened to me to break out a case huh
probably collocation you watch yeah dude
he was super creepy what he's about
sacks of busting nuts on every video
yeah yeah I think he was performing at
the black Expo where we were at really
he was the headliner it's always wet in
every video he's wet yeah I don't trust
him
really not around my girl yeah
definitely if you gotta wear some of
that rain X on your distance to say you
know that's rough
uh speaking of rough dude this thing is
what is it I'd eat that
yeah I'd shoot that no doubt if there's
a couple tough months where the power's
out
I'd eat the [ __ ] out of that thing dude
dude I feel like you're breaking the
house yeah the real
problem on your hands no gun you got
some problems bro you guys can't see
this dog I'm not joking it's standing up
it is seven feet tall
it's tough andre the giant of dogs man
yeah yeah dude yeah who is it I wonder
what one of his parents is obviously
Dennis Rodman okay here's the thing
buddy sleeps in his bed oh my god bro I
hooked up with this girl in Philadelphia
one time beautiful young lady far as
everybody knows and she had a dog that's
slept in her bed and his name was Kobe
and this was right for Kobe got busted
for the alleged sex and it turned out
yeah and I was like I can't sleep in
here with the dog was way bigger than me
man Kobe yeah don't trust him they sleep
in the Middle's up in the middle between
us I had no choice bra was wasted and I
could not even kind of dog was it you
remember that name Kobe oh he was very
great bro I don't know what he was but
he was slightly great I bet you slept
nuts - but - dude he had on socks I
remember socks in a nightie just a hat
on he had on socks I had to get a little
oh [ __ ] on his back glowered he just
smelled good that's the only the only
saving grace arks Cologne and I remember
a whole lot I'm here JAL she might've
been [ __ ] in a row it was a queen bed at
best it could have been a large twin it
could have been a large twin happy
birthday this giant dog what doesn't
yeah how about dad
oh that's just back who made this it's
this is something that Elon Musk made
after blowing that Johnny with [ __ ]
burger you know I'm uh starts making
[ __ ] that don't work he's great
you need mittens after that we're like
whoa yeah they fly that we crave row
[ __ ] Elon Musk made after smoking that
joy
[Music]